getting ready to go iron cowboy in full
effect
where's the wingman due to this plan
base approve good you guys never
disappoint
you
so today is a huge day why is it a huge
day today is Saturday July 25th and this
is the day that the iron cowboy James
Lawrence is going to complete his 50th
Ironman in 50 states in 50 days I
decided to at the last minute
hop a flight to Utah I'm going to drive
out to where he's doing his last Ironman
I'm going to surprise him I think what
he is on the cusp of achieving is one of
the greatest accomplishments in the
history of human endurance
and I just had to be there so is going
to be fun come on along
your power I made it 2-1 Salt Lake
onward $4
thank you wait for my bags all right
in the rental car now and I got to drive
south and try to figure out where the
enter now boy is so I can hook up with
him it's gonna be awesome
alright looks like it's about
- stop it - he's out riding his bike
right now anyway
I think the marathon's would start
around 3 o'clock so I got
and want to get there too early
big surprise
I know I told you I would well no one
has ever come close but he never doubted
himself he was always like yeah I'm
gender percent on why everyone doubting
me like I'm ready to go are you thank
you what are you guys doing what are you
guys doing an iron cowboy then you guys
having a good time you guys ready to run
with the iron cowboy yeah man awesome
oh my god it's a party I can't believe
how many people are here off so we're
gonna change the vibe running gear
I try to greet James when he comes in on
the bike supposedly he's about 15
minutes out or so so
you
yeah
that's will get James a little bit of
food and macking out on the run and then
we'll get ready for the marathon
he did it he did it I'm so proud of
James and his family's beautiful family
it was not on a privilege to be there to
witness what I think is truly one of the
most incredible historic achievements in
the annals of endurance history
basically I just went back to Utah the
following weekend and was able to sit
down with him with his wife sunny with
his daughter Lucy and with the wingmen
Kacy and Aaron and get the whole story
on record it's a two-hour Vulcan
mind-meld and we talked about everything
from what it was like for him to
mentally wrap his head around tackling
such an unbelievable adventure the
perspective of the family his wife Sonny
what it was like for her what it was
like for all the kids and what's next
for James so check that out really proud
of this conversation I'm really touched
by what him and his family his whole
community has been able to do in terms
of inspiring people the world over and I
can't wait to see what he does next so
you can check out the podcast on iTunes
or go to rich roll com
the link to the episode is right down
here let me know what you think of me
doing these videos it's not like I'm
going to be a daily vlog or anything
like that but to the extent that I can
bring you behind the scenes on some of
the cool adventures that I'm privileged
to experience I would like to be able to
continue doing that so look forward to
your thoughts and your comments below
and I will catch you guys next
have great week money